Hey, David, are anti Trump Republicans sort
of a third party now?
Will they become a formal third party going
forward?
My instinct is no.
And I know that a lot of you have been following
very closely groups like the Lincoln Project,
which are made up mostly of disaffected Republicans
who believe that the Republican Party under
Donald Trump is not really the Republican
Party of pre Donald Trump, which is true in
many senses.
And could this split off?
Could this permanently fracture the Republican
Party?
I think the answer is no.
And it's no for a couple of different reasons.
Number one, if the Republican Party for more
formally fractures and you've got.
Sort of like the Trumpy and Republicans and
then more traditional pre pre Trump Republicans.
It helps Democrats dramatically because it
splits the right wing vote.
Republicans know this.
And so it would be dealing a huge amount of
self-inflicted damage if the Democratic Party
doesn't split.
A split in the Republican Party.
Destroys the possibilities of many Republicans
from getting reelected.
So on a practical level, I don't think they're
going to do it.
But there is another reason, which is that
until I see evidence otherwise, these groups
like the Lincoln Project and other anti Trump
Republicans, Mitt Romney, etc., this is temporary.
If Biden wins, things go back to the way they
were in terms of their opposition to Democratic
policy, Democratic ideas, even when the Democratic
ideas are only marginally more left than the
mainstream Republican ideas as they are in
some cases, the Lincoln Project is a it's
a pre Trump Republican Party, and that means
that it is immediately going to go back to
saying what Joe Biden wants to do is bad.
Joe Biden building a climate proposal on the
green New Deal is bad.
Joe Biden wanting to uncap Social Security
earnings and eliminate the stepped up basis
clause and all of that.
They're against all of that stuff.
And so but my my belief is that this ends
as soon as soon as Donald Trump is out of
office.
Now, there's one sort of caveat to this.
A lot of these anti Trump Republicans have
said they aren't going to go back to the Republican
Party, that the idea being they've burnt their
bridges, that by opposing Donald Trump, they've
also ruined relationships with some of the
more traditional mainstream Republicans who
are falling in line with Trump and that that's
an irreparable relationship.
No.
One, history tells us otherwise.
Politics makes strange bedfellows, grudges
that seem an unforgivable, so to speak.
End up being forgiven either explicitly or
implicitly, and those same alliances end up
being formed.
So I just don't believe that the the bridges
have been burned permanently.
The bridges can be rebuilt.
But number two, you can be out of the Republican
Party in some kind of strict technical sense
and still oppose Democrats and still end up
voting for future Republican candidates.
So it's partly that I don't believe them,
but partly it's it could be a technicality
now in terms of my view.
I would love multiple parties and I would
love a different voting system.
I've said before.
The best path to empowering parties other
than Republicans and Democrats in the United
States involves serious campaign finance reform,
number one.
And number two, a different voting system
than first past the post, because for as long
as we continue to have Purt first past the
post, the spoiler effect of supporting a third
party candidate is too great.
If I love the Green Party.
And then would vote Democratic.
And really don't want a Republican, I risk
putting the Republican in office by voting
for the Green Party if on the right.
I am actually so I don't know some far right
neo-Nazi.
And I want David Duke.
But if it's not David Duke, I'd prefer Trump.